plusieurs centaines de personnes ont pu
être rapatriés cet après-midi en russie
un vol spécial d'aero flotte a été
exceptionnellement autorisée pour
l'occasion au départ de l'aéroport de
roissy charles de gaulle
plus de 280 personnes bloquées en france
ont pu être rapatriés vers moscou
ce vol s'inscrit dans une opération de
grande envergure menée par les
ambassades de russie à travers le monde
ici derrière moi on peut acheter les
payer pour prendre l'avion qui va à les
avoir à saint pétersbourg qu'après à
moscou il y a à peu près de 195 passage
et écouter de nos sociétés russes qui
peuvent prendre cet avion pour revenir
en russie
c'était un vol spécial organisé et
roulements de russie pour évacuer les
citoyens russes
si l'opération qui est menée partout
dans le monde
en fait pour la france est aux lock a
maintenu des vols réguliers après
l'introduction des mesures sanitaires en
fait jusqu'au 27 mars après quoi
jusqu'au 30 mars y avait des charters
d'évacuation et depuis tout s'est arrêté
en ce moment au début avril à y rester
quelques trente mille citoyens russes
qui restait à l'étranger mme évacuation
a été organisée mais
les destinations prioritaires de cette
évacuation c'était bien sûr les pays les
plus éloignés